so many different Pixar sequels and
prequels and still no Incredibles -
monsters University is the prequel to
monsters Inc this is where we get to
learn how Mike and Sulley became buddies
at the first place they're at a
university that's all about the scare
games and learning how to be the best
scarer and you have to learn how to
scare children the best way possible and
the film kind of turns into a bit of a
competition movie where they're in this
thing called the scare games trying to
be able to do their best to compete
against other teams who are trying to
prove that they are the scariest
monsters they have the most scares in
them that they can be the most fearsome
monsters and scare all the children of
the world basically the difficulty here
is that we have Mike and Sulley sort of
competing with each other for a while we
get to see how they became friends
because at first they're kind of enemies
but there's also some underlying themes
in the movie where Mike isn't sure if
he's scary enough and Sulley is the big
scary beast and everyone loves him but
he doesn't had the smarts that Mike has
and so they had to kind of learn how to
work together and make their team be the
scariest team and all of monsters
University so they can impress the big
evil Dean this giant dragon lady who's
you know the scariest thing to ever walk
the planet for these people now I saw
monsters Inc when it first came out and
I really enjoyed it but it was never
really like the one that I played over
and over again like Toy Story was I
still enjoyed the film though and so I
was looking forward to see where these
characters were going to go even though
they weren't really going to go
someplace because this is a prequel and
so we get to see how they get to where
they eventually go which is what we've
already seen and I just basically
described or a prequel is an incredibly
unnecessarily convoluted way I apologize
this is a prequel that's oh and it's not
bad at all I actually really enjoyed
monsters University Pixar's been on a
string of mediocrity lately and I think
this is a good way to kind of turn it
around because it's something that
appeals to the Pixar fans because
monsters Inc is one of most people's
favorite movies from Pixar and this is a
way to kind of not just only cash in on
that which I know I'm sure they're
thinking of but also be able to tell a
story that's a little bit closer to
Pixar fans hearts because in my mind
their past few films have been
disappointing don't get me wrong I
enjoyed brave it just wasn't really what
I wanted
- b-but Kars - not a fan not a fan at
all and later this year I'm going to
have to review the cars spin off planes
Ching Pixar good job monsters University
actually has a large amount of heart in
it that was kind of infectious towards
me especially towards the third reel of
the movie do people say third real
anymore I don't know I do towards the
third real this movie I was like you
know what I'm actually really getting
into this it is a little bit cliched how
it kind of goes the Billy Madison route
except for monsters in a cartoon where
you have this competition and you have
to prove yourself and prove your smarts
and prove your scariness I get it that
they were going for that and they made
the film fun and entertaining and it was
cool to see how the characters came
together but it was a little bit cliched
I feel like it's unnecessary at this
point for me to tell you that Pixar's
animation is beautiful but it is it's
very very good the score is also really
great I really enjoyed that aspect of
the film - but it really it's just nice
to see these characters get together and
you can see how they all come together
and it is a pretty funny movie it has a
good sense of humor - it it's just
nothing terribly remarkable until really
the last half and onward the first half
of the movie was just fine you know
you're watching the movie and you're
like okay this is an enjoyable movie I
can see taking your family to this movie
and enjoying it with your kids but
towards the last half of the movie it
actually really started to pick up you
got into the competition and I got to
say without spoiling it the last 15
minutes of the movie were very
unexpected for me I really didn't think
it was going to go in the direction that
it went and I really got to give the
makers of this film praise for that
because it definitely sidetracked from
where I thought it was going and it
really did actually surprise me for that
reason I'm going to give monsters
University of B I think that it's a fun
family film it has great animation it's
not a remarkable Pixar movie it's just a
good time I think your kids are going to
love it and if you are a parent you're
not going to have a hard time watching
it either I think that being said what
do you guys think of monsters University
if you saw it let me know below and
thanks as always for watching guys and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes